when our first guest was a junior in
college a friend asked him what he
planned to do with his life
he said he'd just read a magazine
article in a dentist's office it made
him think he'd become an actuary that
his friend replied would be really
boring the friend convinced him to spend
the next summer at the Earth Observatory
in Palisades New York affiliated with
columbia university that was 1952 he's
been there ever since after earning
three degrees at Columbia then joining
its faculty he rose to become one of the
world's greatest geoscientists often
called the grandfather of climate
science he may be best known among his
peers for identifying what he calls a
great conveyor belt of ocean currents
that crucially influences the Earth's
climate the discovery is regarded as one
of the most significant in the history
of Oceanography he has been a pioneer in
methods to detect how the Earth's
climate has changed over the course of
hundreds of thousands of years he has
shown how climate can change not just
gradually but abruptly with potentially
dire consequences his voice was among
the first and it remains among the most
forceful in sounding the alarms about
the perils posed by the rise of
greenhouse gases in the Earth's
atmosphere and he has not only used deep
scientific analysis to highlight the
problem he has increasingly focused on
the search for effective solutions we
honor the man who has been called the
world's leading interpreter of the
Earth's operation as a biological
chemical and physical system Columbia's
Newberry professor of geology Wallace
broker
Molly broker really the father of my own
to a primary pet a final chemical
ecology and huge legacy of achievement
prescient Poseidon of geoscience
fathoming the depths and currents of
climate change he has peered far into
our planet's past and compelled our
concern for its future Wallace Smith
broker doctor of science 1975 quite some
time ago that his first article on
global room and I take 75 to wrote an
article talking about thee what leads us
to quad whirring that was coming it's
pressing our next guest an illustrious
political scientist has shaped the
understanding of what induces us to come
together rather than to go our separate
ways his career itself has epitomized
cooperation in his remarkable range of
fertile collaborations with scholars
within and beyond his own field his
publications on the evolution and
complexity of cooperation stand among
the world's most frequently cited
writings in the social sciences and he
has brought his theoretical insights to
bear on a sweeping range of problems
from the avoidance of nuclear war to the
nature of biological evolution from
international trade to cybersecurity to
cooperation among cancer cells past
president of the American Political
Science Association he is the
extraordinarily rare social political
scientists to have been honored with the
National Medal of Science his methods
draw on complexity theory game theory
and computer modelling in ways that have
continually shaped the frontier of his
field as a pair of colleagues recently
wrote it is hard to name an act of
political scientist anywhere in the
world whose ideas have
had such a powerful impact on such a
wide range of human inquiry and action
it's not only academics who have felt
his touch when bono was asked the secret
to you tues longevity as a rock band he
reportedly sighted our guest seminal
book on the evolution of cooperation we
probably welcome a rock star of social
science the walgreen professor for the
study of human understanding at the
University of Michigan Robert Axelrod
right behind him is Robert Putnam who
certainly has furthered that field of
the evolution of cooperation absolutely
impelled by the perils of nuclear war
intrigued by biology's complex puzzles a
paramount scholar of cooperation and
modeling and a model of scholarly
cooperation robert m Axelrod Doctor of
Laws beautiful citation
what's that smell you should ask our
next guest
one of the world one of the world's
foremost experts on the biology of
sensory perception she discovered how
molecules in the environment are
detected by tiny receptors in the nose
then translated by the brain into
specific smells her work marked a
breakthrough in solving a long-standing
scientific enigma it showed that the elf
olfactory system in mammals is far more
complex than had been understood earlier
with hundreds of different receptors
responsible for detecting tens of
thousands of different odors born in
Seattle to a mother who loved word
puzzles and the father who was an
electrical engineer she developed an
early fascination with science as a
postdoc at Columbia she played a crucial
role in first identifying odor receptors
then as a member of the Harvard Medical
School faculty for a decade she broke
open her field by showing how the brain
organizes signals from those receptors
to let us perceive a vast multitude of
sense for her path breaking discoveries
about the olfactory system she shared a
Nobel Prize in 2004 and thus she
discovered the sweet smell of success
concluding her Nobel autobiography she
wrote I sincerely hope that my receiving
this prize will send a message to young
women everywhere that the doors are open
to them and that they should follow
their dreams
we welcome back to Harvard an
investigator of the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute a professor at the
University of Washington and a leading
member of the Fred Hutchinson Cancer
Research Center Linda buck a brilliant
medical researcher now we recognize
she's being escorted by a Katherine
doula aficionado of olfaction pioneer in
the perception of common and uncommon
sense her research on receptors has
revolutionised what science nose of the
nose Linda buck doctor of science
utterly brilliant citation wonderful
science nose of the nose
can see on stage Linda greenhouse two
people back she grew up here in
Cambridge the daughter of a poet and a
Harvard economics professor she studied
history and literature at Radcliffe then
received her PhD in fine arts from
Harvard 50 years after her first Harvard
doctorate we welcome her home for an
honorary second to recognize her career
as one of the most original and
influential art historians of her
generation decades ago she sees the
attention of art scholars with her book
the art of describing which one critic
called the most brilliant erudite and
provocative attempt to characterize 17th
century Dutch art in many years her
publications have transformed the
understanding of works by Dutch masters
such as Vermeer and Rembrandt as well as
other painters including Rubens
Velazquez da below and Mazari she is
perhaps best known for an approach that
features what has been called radical
clothes looking focusing intently on
pictures paintings as pictures that
describe the world rather than his works
that embed narratives and hidden
meanings from her early days choosing to
focus on Dutch art when Italian art was
more involved she has dared to be
different challenging the conventions of
her field and inspiring independence of
mind in others you can't write anything
first-rate she has said without getting
attacked from her first article one
colleague rice she has surprised
delighted and vexed her readers with
novel readings and viewings of artists
about whom it would seem we had said it
all we honor a professor emeritus at the
University of California at Berkeley and
a longtime member of the Harvard family
Svetlana alpers
art historian twice doctorate
connoisseur of the craft of informed
looking transformative force in the
history of art she posits that pictures
need eyes and not words and spurs us to
see the familiar anew Svetlana Leon TF
Alpers doctor of arts beautiful our next
guest is perhaps best known as the
nimble-fingered bass player for the
legendary musical group the professor's
of bluegrass he also moonlights is
president of a modestly selective
University in South Central Connecticut
perhaps best known for having come
agonisingly close to completing an
undefeated ID football season last fall
but but not quite his professors of
bluegrass are revered for such favorite
says I'm blue I'm lonesome I've injured
man in the middle dim lights thick smoke
that wistful tune dear to the hearts of
fundraisers everywhere I ain't broke and
that old classic I'm just an old chunk
of coal but I'm going to be a diamond
someday all these Tunes richly evoke the
boundless pleasures and the occasional
perplexities of his day job his service
since July 2013 as the 23rd president of
our dearly beloved and occasionally
rivalry sibling Yale University after
college at Stanford he landed in New
Haven some 35 years ago since then he
has done just about everything a Yale
man possibly could do
two masters degrees the PhD professor of
psychology founder of the health
emotional and behavioral laboratory
leading figure in interdisciplinary
research centers on aids and cancer
department chair dean of the college
dean of the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences and of course the exalted role
of University Provost he is an
extraordinary scholar a pioneer in
developing the concept of emotional
intelligence or AI he is an
extraordinary teacher winner of Yale
teaching prizes and mentor to countless
grateful students above all he is an
extraordinary human being an embodiment
of the emotional intelligence studies
studies in others and someone who in one
colleagues words is just an
astonishingly human guide not only that
but he assures us he has already signed
up for cs50 next fall with familial
pride and a hearty bow wow wow
the elfin we honor a native son of
Cambridge Massachusetts our friend and
colleague Peter salivate you know I know
Peter I serve on his heels Advisory
Council as a yes you really have
extraordinary quality of education for
undergraduates there superlatives
psychologists and bulldog and chief who
likes his very toss with a dash of
Luke's a warm and wise Eli of high E I
whose world like his grass is ever Blue
Peter Sal of a doctor of laws you know I
think she writes these South patient's
herself and then you're quite wonderful
beautiful what is right together or even
get her backside girl yeah I'm sure you
can't understand most of the important
things from a distance his grandmother
used to tell him you have to get close
since his days as a student at our law
school and Kennedy School he has devoted
his life to getting closer and closer to
the American criminal justice system and
two scores and scores of people accused
or convicted of crimes many of them
sentenced to die the closer he has come
to that system and to the people within
it the more resolute ly he has affirmed
his core belief the true measure of our
character he writes is how we treat the
poor the disfavored the accused the
incarcerated and the condemned that
belief has shaped his career as one of
the nation's most admired and effective
Public Interest lawyers devoted to
serving death row inmates juvenile
offenders people wrongly convicted or
charged with violent crimes poor people
denied effective representation and
others whose trials have been marked by
racial bias or prosecutorial misconduct
he is the founder and leader of the
equal justice initiative based in
Montgomery Alabama his organization
carries forward its work in four broad
domains race and poverty children in
prison mass incarceration and the death
penalty in the words of one criminal
justice expert he surely has done as
much as any other living American to
vindicate the innocent and temper
justice with mercy for the guilty and
informs far beyond the courtroom he has
spoken and written with searing
eloquence about the meaning of justice
and mercy in a nation so often focused
on punishment and retribution he urges
that we face up to the volatile
interplay of race poverty and justice in
America and he does so in a spirit not
of rancor of hope we probably honor
Bryan Stevenson
and a great model I mean for so many of
these law students there in public
interest law is really primal force
there somewhere
this is
his deep conviction that justice must be
done has undone convictions of the
wrongly accused tireless dauntless his
eyes on the prize he presses on the
upward way to point us toward a higher
ground Bryan Stevenson doctor of laws
what a wonderful chance really our
commitment to public service she started
out teaching high school in Deep Creek
Virginia a stone's throw from wetlands a
stone's throw throw from wetlands known
as the Great Dismal Swamp in the years
to follow she emerged as a preeminent
figure in American education and a
historic figure at Harvard a graduate of
Purdue and Columbia she led Barnard
colleges education program for a decade
she built an academic career as one of
the premier scholars of the history of
American education and of women in
education in 19 in 1974 she became a
vice president of Radcliffe College and
a professor at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education in 1977 she accepted
President Carter's appointment to direct
the National Institute of Education a
federal agency dedicated to education
research she returned to Cambridge and
in 1982 was named dean of harvard
faculty of education the first woman
ever to serve as dean of one of
harvard's faculties
she led our EDS school with distinction
for nearly a decade she sharpened its
focus on k12 public schooling she deep
in its attention to the persistent
inequalities in American education her
trailblazing has never been about
seizing the limelight one colleague
writes it has always been focused on
bringing her enormous energy political
instincts and good judgment to the
labors of leadership scholarship and
community building she has served as
president of both the Spencer Foundation
and the National Academy of education as
chair of the Carnegie Foundation as vice
president of both the american
historical association and the american
academy of arts and sciences when
educational institutions look for
leadership and wisdom they know where to
turn today it is our turn to salute our
own charles warren professor of the
history of American education America
Patricia Graham
her escort right behind her is Sarah
moves left foot that's the cat brain
very well known in this community other
people
how schooling can foster both knowledge
and virtue has set the syllabus for her
singular life and adroit leader and
trustee trustee she has not just
illuminated history but made it Patricia
albergue Ram Doctor of Laws most use
private includes at least one member
retired faculty and wisdom honorary
degrees in this year it's Patricia grant
as a boy in the former Belgian Congo he
accompanied his father a pastor to
minister to the sick one day a sick
child asked the pastor for medicine the
pastor explained he was not a doctor and
so thought the pastor's son a doctor is
what I must someday he as he grew up he
saw the distressing leap or medical
resources for women in his country so he
went to France where he studied to
become a gynecologist in the years since
he has emerged as a heroic figure in the
Democratic Republic of Congo there he
has devoted his heart and soul to caring
for women and girls who have survived
the brutal sexual violence endemic to
the conflict that has plagued the
country for almost two decades militias
and gains have deployed rape as a weapon
of war bringing devastation to
individuals families entire communities
he founded the Panzi Hospital known
worldwide for its leadership in treating
survivors of sexual violence there he
directs a program that tends not only to
his patients physical abuse but to their
psychological trauma as well
and he does not stop there he seeks the
survivors reintegration into society
through vocational programs and access
to social services countless women and
girls have been the beneficiaries of his
care far beyond his hospital he has
become an impassioned international
advocate for Congolese women demanding
attention to the barbarity that they
continue to endure and urging an end to
the violence in 2012 armed intruders
took his daughters hostage they shot his
security guard to death they fired at
him and he narrowly escaped
assassination before the assailants fled
the scene still he carries on a
recipient of the sakharov prize for
human rights and numerous honors
worldwide he maintains his faith and
courage in the face of the unspeakable
the power of darkness will be defeated
he insists we must respond to violence
with love we honor dr. Denis mukwege a
Dennis with the founder of the Ponzi
extraordinary both in others as a
surgeon but also I think of everyone is
why Zimmerman who's his escort is
Jennifer leaning who is the head of the
FHP symbol for full human rights
atmosphere republica that's why the
Jennifer was the
she allergic even talk so much
of inspired choice this an incarnation
of courage and compassion giving succor
to his country's women of Valor for him
it is always a time to heal and a time
to build up a time to love and a time
for peace Denis mukwege a doctor of
science that combination with science
servicing medicine including right is so
critical come be a compassion with also
if you've ever doubted whether the words
diva and divine share the same origin
you need only listen to our next guest
same as you have I cannot imagine a more
satisfying calling than my own she
writes beauty humanity and history every
day combined with the cathartic joy of
singing multiply her own joy by millions
and you begin to measure the
exhilaration that her singing brings two
admirers around the world she grew up
the daughter of two vocal music teachers
in a home where singing filled the air
at age three she gave her first solo
performance in the indelible role of
Suzy snowflake by grade school it was
the sound of music in my fair lady after
singing jazz in college and graduate
study at Eastman and Juilliard she
assented to Opera's upper echelons as a
Contessa in the houston grand opera's
marriage of figaro and then as Mimi in
the New York operas La Boheme before
long she was gracing the stage of the
Metropolitan Opera where she has by now
made more than 220 performances in 21
roles among her hundreds of memorable
performances and her scores of leading
roles on stages worldwide her vast
repertoire ranges from Strauss to Mozart
from Hondo to mass nee from Verity to
for Jacques did I hear for Jacques
acclaimed by predicts beloved by
audiences she is known for a soprano
voice described as sumptuous magnificent
transcendent a voice likened to
glistening silver or double cream opera
star recording artist champion of new
music sometime jazz and indie rock
singer author television host teacher
literacy advocate fashion icon Broadway
leading lady recipient of the national
medal of arts possessor of what many
have simply called America's beautiful
voice singers she once wrote have a
complicated relationship with applause I
ask that you join me in making this an
extremely complicated moment for Renee
Fleming
sometimes called the people's diva
because she has such a the things that
is
to everyone consummate Contessa sobraon
o soprano sublime exalting her art for
exultant audiences renowned for her
areas but not for her heirs when her
voice soars our hearts sing Renee
Fleming doctor of music such an
inspiration and was the low- we have an
opera every year in
inspiration for them to absolutely he
has lived what he calls an improbable
life he grew up in poverty on Chicago's
South Side after junior high he found
his way to Milton Academy in
Massachusetts thanks to an organization
fittingly called a better chance he
tells the story of heading off to his
first day of class at Milton mindful
that boys were required to wear jackets
and ties he arrived a class in his best
jacket a sporty blue windbreaker fresh
off the rack from Sears he looked around
at the blue blazers in Tweed and
realized he'd entered a totally
unfamiliar world not just a different
place he has said but a different planet
he learned to navigate planet Milton den
Harvard College after a fellowship year
in Sudan he conquered Harvard Law School
he launched his legal career as a public
spirited young lawyer at the end of a CP
Legal Defense Fund after time and
private practice he rose to become the
nation's top civil rights officer as
assistant attorney general for civil
rights after senior positions in the
corporate world he made his first bid
for elected office as a relative unknown
mounting a grassroots campaign for
governor of Massachusetts as we all know
against the odds he won in his inaugural
speech he invoked the early
Massachusetts settlers who saw their new
home as a shining city on a hill to this
kid from the south side of Chicago he
said Massachusetts is my shining
on a hill and for the next eight years
he invested his all in making it shine
in education healthcare innovation
Economic Opportunity equality and
inclusion life sciences and technology
environmental responsibility perhaps
most of all in seeking to inspire a
sense of true Commonwealth a community
in which each cares about the well-being
of all at our best he has said we are
for each other we are about seeing our
own stake in our neighbors dreams and
struggles as well as our own that belief
not only echoes through his public
announcements it has shown tree every
aspect of his remarkable if improbable
life it is a special pleasure to
recognize the 71st governor of the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts and of a
least equal note of fellow alumnus of
dunster house
the Honorable deval Patrick faculty
given a standing ovation for the service
the ball when he was here they call them
first gen the first generation of his
family to attend college and he was and
now that first generation is fourteen
percent of this graduating class
exemplar and exponent of the American
dream embracing Commonwealth as a lived
ideal he has warned his Excellency with
humility and grace while kindling in
others a reason to believe Duvall L
Patrick doctor of laws governor patrick
the final hour and he will of course be
giving we address this afternoon at two
o'clock in the name of this society of
scholars I declare that these persons
are entitled to the rights and
privileges pertaining to their several
degrees and that their names are to be
forever born on its role of honorary
members